Stephen King's it is a wildly ambitious
story and there are plenty of details
you may not be aware of all things
you've simply forgotten about the first
installment here's a look at everything
you need to know before seeing it
chapter 2 at the end of it the kids cut
their hands and swear a blood oath to
one another promising to return to Derry
if the creature ever returns it's
chapter 2 sees the blood oath realized
as a creature commonly known as
Pennywise a dancing clown does indeed
resurface after 27 years when it returns
the losers Club is scattered across the
United States with US members or leading
very different lives in the book build
embryo has become a best-selling
suspense novelist Ben Hanscom is a
successful architect living in Nebraska
Richie Tozier is a DJ in Los Angeles
Eddie Kaz Brak runs a limousine company
in New York City Stanley Yaris is a
partner at an accounting firm in Atlanta
Beverly Marsh is a successful fashion
designer living in Chicago and married
to an abusive husband though most of the
losers moved away from Derry one member
stayed behind Mike Hanlon the orphan boy
whose family's history is deeply tied to
the violence and hatred brought on by
Pennywise
since Mike stayed in Derry he sacrificed
his own potential because the creatures
supernatural influence acts as a kind of
suppressant Mike becomes a historian of
the group and Yvette's
in King's novel he keeps a detailed
journal filled with research about what
it is when the creatures feeding cycle
starts again mike is a person who
reaches out to the other members of the
losers Club reminding them of the oath
they took and asking them to come back
and help without spoiling anything we'll
just say it's a life that definitely
takes a toll on Mike since it chapter
two is a sequel it obviously expands a
world of the original film and there are
plenty of fresh faces in the movie too
well
maybe fresh isn't quite the word we're
looking for here but tell me how is it
being back in Derry while bill skarsgård
will definitely be returning to play
Pennywise the dancing clown the film
also features a frightening new form for
the creature
mrs. Kirsch she's a seemingly sweet
elderly woman who lives in Beverly's old
apartment and she's probably featured in
the film's first trailer despite initial
appearances she is not a friendly
presence I was always a nice girl
what about you in the novel three
homophobic teenagers attack a gay man
named Adrian melon portrayed in its
chapter two by actor writer and director
Xavier Dolan in the book Mellon is
thrown off a bridge and subsequently
attacked and killed by penny wise this
is one of the most disturbing scenes in
King's massive novel and it wasn't
included in the 1990 miniseries
adaptation but screenwriter Gary
Doberman has confirmed the hate crime
will definitely be featured in its
chapter two he told The Hollywood
Reporter it is the first attack in
present-day dari and sets the stage for
what dari has become it's pure evil what
happens to Adrian these bullies working
through Pennywise was important for us
to show it was a very dark movie
featuring a child murder in the first 10
minutes and a terrifying trip into the
dairy sewers to fight the monster in the
film's finale
according to screenwriter Gary Doberman
each chapter to effectively doubles down
on the horror he told sci-fi wire
I think it's darker and a lot of weights
on the first one the two movies feel
like a complete whole to me according to
pennyways actor bill skarsgård a lot of
the horror stems from the villains new
mindset he wasn't killed by the losers
Club but he was wounded and felt fear
for the very first time in his life
skarsgård told Entertainment Weekly fear
feels hatred and anger towards the kids
there will be adults in this one so I
think there might be an even more
vicious Pennywise he's really going
after it the first heir to recreated a
number of key moments from King's novel
including a famous sequence in which
Beverly Marsh is tormented by penny wise
in a bathroom this results in gallons of
blood shooting out of the sink that a
father can't stay but the blood is
clearly visible to the other members of
the losers Club who clean every inch of
the bathroom it's a very bloody scene
but apparently at chapter 2 is going to
be even bloodier actress Jessica
Chastain who plays the adult Beverly
Marsh described an extremely gory
sequence during an interview with Jimmy
Fallon there's a scene that someone said
on set that it's the most blood that's
ever been in a horror film
seeing him in a scene we don't know the
context of the scene yet for the first
chapter to trailer does feature Beverly
swimming through what seems to be a
literal room of blood we'll find out for
sure how much blood is being spilled
when it's chapter 2 lunges into theaters
on September 6th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about it chapter two are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you